Bill Nye is the trend all over he has
his new flat Netflix show Bill Nye the
not-so scientist guy listen here's
something I want to be clear but I want
to set this up
Bill Nye was originally up he was like a
stand-up comedian a sketch comedian and
he is he has a bachelors I believe I
believe a bachelor's in mechanical
engineering so he's not really what most
people would consider a scientist but
let's allow that and say that he's a
scientist in that field it doesn't mean
that he's an expert in another field my
issue here with Bill Nye is Bill Nye is
almost a walking appeal to Authority
fallacy in the sense that I don't think
you need to be a scientist to criticize
a scientists ideas or to come up with
some kind of a scientific discovery you
just need to be using the scientific
method I get that so I don't want to
just try and discredit Bill Nye because
he claims he's the Science Guy the issue
I have is that Bill Nye is the first guy
to tell everybody else that they have no
right to debate or be skeptical because
he's a scientist and all the scientists
agree with him we have in science
community are looking for an explanation
why climate change deniers or extreme
skeptics do not accept the overwhelming
scientific evidence for climate change
in the most reasonable explanation is
you have a worldview and then you have
evidence and the evidence disagrees with
your worldview so you deny the evidence
and then with that you deny the
authorities that are providing the
evidence you have them not deny Zia
Socrates now we're going to be talking
about gender today because he was he was
he's making the case that gender exists
on a spectrum by the way very different
few go back to his old show he did say
the chromosomes determine gender if you
go back to the episode when we were so
he's done a 180 about 2017 just changes
scientists yeah completely changes
science again I think it's important
because he's a track record he's so anti
any even remote but critical or
skepticism of the idea of catastrophic
man-made climate change he's okay with
them being jailed you know what's your
thought on jailing skeptics as war
criminals we'll see what happens was it
appropriate to jail the guys from Enron
interesting okay right so we'll see what
happens so I mean again but they'll say
anyone who disagrees with them is the
extremists that you're the extreme you
should jail have only disagrees with me
the people who disagree with me they're
the extremists here's here's the thing -
just because let's say you are a
scientist in one field it doesn't
that you're an expert in another field
Bill Nye is a mechanical engineer okay
so he's not an atmospheric scientist
even though he's been you know
championing that the climate change
cause and in perhaps silencing and
jailing skeptics he's not a biologist
he's not a doctor so he wouldn't be an
expert in gender or biological sex not
saying as the other right to have an
opinion but again that sort of matters
just like in a field of medicine you can
be a doctor but it doesn't mean that
you're qualified in all realms of
medicine okay bypass should be a piece
of cake now count back from 10 is that
anesthesia kicks in I was so glad I had
the best heart surgeon in New York 10
I'm a podiatrist this is just my passion
[Music]
so now here's the thing can doctors also
have opinions in other fields for
example yeah absolutely think so I think
anyone here can have an opinion on ideas
in science or ideas put forth by
certainly by scientists particularly
scientists are putting forth
unscientific ideas and I think a good
example there would be listen if your
doctors listen I'm an MD okay I'm not a
dietician but if your dietitian is
advising you as some do a high
carbohydrate low saturated fat diet I
would advise you to do some research I
personally believe that that's wrong
that's perfectly fine for that doctor to
do just like it's perfectly fine for
Bill Nye to say listen I'm not a
biologist I'm not a doctor I don't have
a PhD I actually have about as I'm about
as qualified to deal with the topic of
gender as anybody in this room or
watching this video but I now think it
exists on a spectrum that's why this
matters I never try and discredit
someone just if some I know people
who've never graduated grade school who
are by no mechanics who are more
brilliant than doctors and I know
doctors who are dumber than Kardashians
coming down to the ideas
Bill Nye decided to do an entire episode
on gender I'm just trying to get my head
around it maybe you can tell me it seems
as though the show had absolutely
nothing to do with science let's cycle
through some of his example first off
you had a panel of people on there who
were who were gender enthusiasts it
doesn't necessarily seem peer-reviewed
which again doesn't always have to be
but Bill Nye acts as though it always
has to be with his his to track
they let in with this ice cream video
let's see this there are lots of flavors
to sexuality oh this again come on now
I've spoken to some of you about my
theories on the nature of being ice
cream which have no basis in science
it's the science of feelings and as
vanilla I feel that I am the most
natural of the ice creams and therefore
the rest of you should just go ahead and
also be vanilla no one can make you stop
being strawberry strawberry strawberry
[Music]
everyone should pretend to be vanilla
until they no longer have the urge not
to be vanilla what you don't need dennis
prager on last week i said i truly
believe that the left is more about
feelings and the right is more about
about facts about using logic we've
talked about the Socratic method now I
know the let but here's what the left
does they Disick use the right of being
anti science right
and what do they mean they mean anyone
who's critical of our brand of science
we believe that the EPA can fix manmade
climate change well hold on a second I'm
not sure if we want to you are a science
denier we believe that transgenderism is
biological we'll hold on a second
there's a you or a science denier so now
they've actually created an umbrella so
why'd the science of feelings no
feelings are feelings and Sciences
science we're not talking about any kind
of synapse ease or we're not talking
about neurotransmitters here he's not
making that argument he's not even
making an analogy he's trying to say we
need to acknowledge the science of
feelings in order to continue along with
this narrative he also used another
example going down the trail boat
haven't heard a lot of people bring up
but he brings up the clownfish and he
says are you are you aware that the
clownfish can change his sex okay I
understand somehow this is this a
scientific method that applies to humans
I mean we use rats for studies as an
indicator as to how something might
perform in humans with drugs and
supplements and we always have to say
listen by the way hasn't been studying
humans it's only been studied in rats so
that's a 50/50 crapshoot we don't really
know I've not heard of it any
double-blind placebo-controlled clinical
trials with clownfish
the clownfish continues sex my dog looks
his balls how is this relevant to the
idea of biological sex or gender next
then it culminates in this I some slam
poetry a song about gender
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah well it's a science of feelings
Stephanie speech no hate speech in my
studio I'm watching this going what does
any of this have to do with science for
a guy who claims that all of his his
detractors our unscientific for a guy
who claims I'm the science guy and has
this qualification superiority based on
his pedigree as a mechanical engineer
what does any of this have to do with
science and he kind of wrapped it up
finally getting into the chromosome
issue was very brief talking about xx
and talking about XY he does the
chromosome fit and then he goes into a
very short very short as well you know
and now some scientists or some doctors
are maybe believing that the male brain
and the female brain particularly the
male to female transgender might
actually have more in common with the
female brain than a male brain in other
words saying that brains can have
genders brains can have a biological sex
now here's the thing he makes that
argument we'll talk about that on
Thursday more in depth there's one study
that makes that we've talked about how
actually the brain changes occurred
after cross-sex hormones replacement
therapy and a lot of transgender people
were mad and they cite one study where
it deals more so with gray matter in the
brain well there have been numerous
studies since then trying to recreate
that study with more reliable forms of
studies that have never been able to
prove that Bill Nye is saying maybe some
doctors now believe that it's possible
with the brain issue well again science
bill nye isn't the burden of proof at
that point on you isn't the burden of
proof if we've always said that men are
men and women are women or by the way
when you go to the chromosome argument
say some chromosomes that sometimes you
know DNA can genetically mutate it's
usually not a net positive
we're usually talking about some kind of
a bizarre illness disease that's usually
with genetic mutation extra-wide doesn't
make you an x-men super boy and by the
way I don't know people out there can
maybe send me I've never seen any kind
of a study even when they bring up the
chromosome issue I've never seen any
definitive study saying well this type
of a chromosome actually is directly
related to transgenderism to the idea
I've seen people say well you know what
chromosomes aren't entirely reliable
therefore transgenderism I've never seen
them saying but we actually have a
hypothesis which we can test we see this
kind of a particular difference or
anomaly in human DNA in the human sorry
in human chromosomes and that tends to
give one a proclivity towards
transgenderism send it to me I haven't
seen it Sciences hypothesis tested
conclusion he's testing nothing and
coming to the conclusion that now gender
is on a spectrum because feeling and of
course the big irony that jared has
brought up and several guests have
talked about if the idea that there
there's this idea that there can be a
male brain and a female brain and this
is the basis on which modern sort of
gender identity is predicated right well
actually someone can be the wrong brain
can be born into the wrong body a female
brain in a male body well it blows up
the entire hypothesis to begin with
because we've since said that gender is
a social construct
well gender is a gender can't be a
social construct if someone is born with
say wrong brain which you are saying is
biologically a male brain and a female
brain even more so if we're using it as
a constant if we were saying there is
such a reliable a format for what a male
brain looks like in a female brain that
there is an anomaly and an outlier with
transgender or gender dysphoria of
people that it's clear they're born with
the wrong brain again that has to be so
remarkably consistent that gender
couldn't possibly be a social construct
but Bill Nye simply wants to say the
science of feelings gender exists on a
spectrum and that's why he's Bill Nye
the not-so science II douchebag arrogant
guy
you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit.com
slash mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips plus
this hand etched mug oh I just when I
feel it I got a chill like on the inside